Charlie Charlie are we safe yeah so
after a brief investigation we've
decided that this Charlie Charlie thing
is kind of just an Internet hoax Charlie
Charlie are you there Charlie Charlie
are you there Charlie Charlie are you
here Charlie Charlie are you in a
chocolate factory so for the duration of
this video I'm just gonna mess with
people
[Music]
man I don't mess with ghosts
I am so superstitious I don't know why
I'm doing this don't know if I can set
this I'm like my nerves are a little I'm
a little shaky you're shaking I know
it's terrifying
Charlie Charlie can we play Charlie's
here Charlie is in the building
it ain't Charlie it's somebody else
grandma died with you man Charlie Choi
do you wanna hurt us
oh my god I think I'm dying
Charlie Charlie can we play no no no no
no no no no no no really no stop if this
is the thing you need to stop it what
what are you doing Oh Charlie Charlie
will you appear
[Music]
he appeared right next to you what I'm
Charlie hi no it's bringing millions and
millions of people together right I
guess there's some some benefit to all
this all connecting over in Mexican
demon so thank you Charlie
oh and just for safety sake goodbye
Charlie Charlie Charlie will mean my BAE
work out oh no
[Music]